I don't know my cell phone number
I love phones I love my cell phone
I love the communication it provides but
I don't know my cell phone number
because when people know your cell
number then they call you and I don't
like unscheduled interruptions the cell
phone phone calls coming in are one of
the biggest interruptions that you can
have in not only your business but your
life and I try to avoid it at all costs
so I don't know my cell phone number so
I can't give it out to anybody listen
when you're working on something can
you're working on a project and somebody
calls you unscheduled what happens first
of all the phone the ringing distracts
you and you try to get back to work with
the ringing distract you wonder who is
it who's calling so you got to go check
right you check your call display who is
this person God do I really want to talk
to this person or not you know you have
to decide then you pick up the phone if
you do you answer it and even if it's a
10-minute conversation now you're
thinking about that person you're
thinking about what they want and you've
totally forgotten what you were doing
before you answered the phone
so I preferred not having the phone ring
at all I don't want people calling me
I'm happy to do business over the phone
but not unscheduled calls how long is it
going to take half an hour forty minutes
an hour to get back into the flow that
you were at when that phone call
happened I don't want those kind of
interruptions I value my time and you
should value yours as well the only
people will have my phone number are my
family and my agent and they know only
to call me when it's super important
right if there's an emergency you need
to reach me okay I got my phone you know
how to reach him but everything else not
super important don't call me because I
value my time in my business but also my
personal life that I'm hanging out with
my son or if I'm you know having some
dinner with my family I don't want
people calling me I don't people
interrupting that I'm doing something so
value your time make it important if you
don't value your time people are gonna
walk all over you if you don't respect
your time they won't respect it either
so make your time mean something do
something important with your time stop
picking up the phone
stop giving out your cell number and
better yet don't know you're still
number at all mix everything easier
believe for those of you watching like
the video give it a thumbs up below you
want to see more you want more
productivity tips you got a question for
me ask me below in the questions in the
comments I'll make a video response
thank you so much and I'll see you soon